women don't talk to each other like
gross about sex the way guys do I feel
like like I don't sit around my
girlfriends be like you guys like
queefed like I don't even talk to my
girlfriends about I'll talk to complete
strangers about it but I don't like sit
around with my girlfriend and be like so
like this circum uncircumcised got
caught in my throat or whatever yeah
we're we're it's too graphic but like on
stage we have that mouthpiece to be like
it's time to talk about some stuff I
think people think Comics who are
talking about sex or promiscuous but I'm
like no I'm more just like being very
I'm not hiding anything I'm talking
about all aspects of sex good and bad
cuz sometimes you think people who are
bragging about not bragging but talking
about their a lot means like I just
understand sex I'm a sex goddess but
it's more like I want to be a mouthpiece
to show like sometimes sex is great but
sometimes sex goes Ary and we all can
like figure it out together so here's
the thing that bothers me when people
like female commans talk about sex okay
do you want to hear us talk about
politics is that what you want so funny
I wrote a bit because I was afraid
people are gonna she just talks about
sex and I wrote it about abortion and
guns and I don't know if if that's what
they want either I don't know it's
interesting because it's also like
comedy doesn't age well regardless you
know what I'm saying so it's like I was
talking about squirting like eight years
ago or something people like when all
she does is talk about sex it's like
well all you do is watch old specials
like I don't know what to tell you know
what I mean it was like at the time that
was something and that is like the token
thing to say also also don't come no I
know don't watch it so I was has anyone
ever you know how hard it is to watch a
female comedian
perform you know how difficult it is to
see a female comedian do a a standup
show like are we are people are female
Comics just running up to you on the
street and being like my like there's
you don't you can go your whole life
never seeing a female comedian we're
basically invisible like we're at like
the House of Blues that's under
construction like they H like we do
shows on like Tuesdays like you never
have to see us when people like all
female Comics they turn our mic off when
we go on
stage I'm like did this just break the
second I took a mic dude I've never
gotten in the algorithm not one time so
like people talk about like all what
fale Comics do is talk about sex like
when when is the last time you they saw
an ad for like a Nicki Glazer special
they saw an ad but it starts
muted you pressed on mute like you how
did we get here I'm actually not even
that dirty my set like people I think
they assume it's going to be a type of
way and it's like I'm just coming up
with whoever thoughts I think will make
people giggle like it's not that serious
what can I make people laugh about stand
up comedy I hate when people take it too
seriously I'm like I I was like killing
with my little niece who's 2 years old
and I was like this that's comedy like I
was the other people were not doing it I
was like nailing the timing I was doing
like like and she was loving it in that
moment I was like and that's why I'm a
professional comedian like it's an
energy sure but it's also like no one's
like I think the Three Stooges are
hacked they're just like like what we're
fine with like sound effects we're fine
with like I actually I've been I had
these like Kevin James like I can fall
off a tread
too I have these uh i' call them hand on
the street but I do these Street
interviews sure and they started doing
well and someone was like that's so
hacky man on the street I'm like I
didn't invent man on the street but like
our podcast hacky everyone has a podcast
but also who hold on who said that well
a comedian who was it was it Norman
Lear was it Chris Rock like who was it
no do you ever like walk into H&R Block
and there's like four cubicles and
you're like he's doing the same thing
you know what I'm saying you go into
like a Claire's and you're like there's
a Claire's in Minnesota and the girl
sells the same earring like what an
account and be like hack you're using
the same W9 is everyone else you guys
this is oh you're using a microphone
pretending do that like what are you
doing what what do you mean but you know
what's interesting I'm coming up with
the algorithm which means I've somehow
cultivated this like like my show can be
like 90% women mhm and their boyfriends
who are like learning like oh this is
fun I actually like what's going on or
like I'll I make fun of the guys so
they'll bring their boyfriends and the
guys like attention but it's like i'
I've been very kind of protected in my
up and up where like I've performed for
mostly women a lot in my career like you
walk in and it's like a girls locker
room and we're all just like swinging
our panties around throwing tampons it's
crazy that's sick but like you had to do
that for me to even like have the
opportunity to get there huh
I had to do what you had to do comedy
like you had to be there for me to even
think I could be there and then tell
girls like yeah comedy is a thing it's a
thing I
mean thanks take the credit okay just
take it I don't know how this works she
said something else downstairs she's
like you had to do this so I could do
this and I was just like did I help you
by accident no you did that was not the
goal no but it could even you could even
as annoying did I just make it look so
easy you're like I could do that
definitely when I watched the female
brain I said if if I can create what I
want to create like she is I think I
could like she made something no one
wanted to see how could I I could
just